You may have laughed at the idea of 'Silent
But Deadly' farts.
But is this faint flatulence really more potent
than the boisterous wind you let loose?
Are silent farts worse?
It may surprise you to find out that a large
portion of farts are the result of swallowed
air.
Whether from chewing a lot of gum, drinking
pop, or simply from eating food, excess air
enters your body and has to go somewhere.
And while some is released through burping,
the rest ends up in the digestive system and
eventually comes out your other end.
But when expelled, this gas is made of mostly
nitrogen, hydrogen and carbon dioxide -- all
of which are odourless.
Which explains why some farts are obnoxiously
loud, but contain little to no smell.
The second half of the equation is gas from
the large intestine.
After travelling through 25 feet of small
intestine, the indigestible portions of food
make their way to the colon.
Here, millions of bacteria feast on the remaining
food, and ferment it.
And this is where things can get...stinky!
Though the bacteria do release some useful
vitamins, they also produce chemicals containing
sulfur, which is responsible for the smell
in flatulence.
Add to that a sulfur rich diet with things
like eggs, meat or broccoli, and you're likely
to produce some interesting odours.
The longer these foods stay in the gut, the
more they ferment and smell.
Still, this smelly portion accounts for around
only 1% of most farts.
In the absence of the other odourless gases,
however, these farts are concentrated with
smell and generally quiet because there is
less volume.
Silent, but deadly!
Having said that, loud gas can be just as
smelly as the quiet ones, if the sulfur components
are there.
Simply put, your loud farts likely contain
a higher proportion airborne, odourless gases,
whereas the quieter flatulence tends to have
a higher proportion of the smell.
Got a burning question you want answered?
Ask it in the comments or on Facebook and
Twitter.
And if you want the inside scoop on upcoming
episode ideas and behind the scenes, check
out our personal Instagram and twitter handles,
and subscribe for more weekly science videos.